producer Michael Narducci
[Applause]
please give a round of applause for
Danny
anyway
[Applause]
Klaus himself Joseph Morgan mr. Charles
Michael David's
[Applause]
Danielle Campbell
and last but by no means least executive
producer and creator Julie black we just
watch that incredible trailer when you
sort of look at season 2 in the hole
what is the theme coming into this year
what do what are you guys trying to come
out I think we talk a lot you know the
sins of the past coming to haunt us to
the presence we talked about the return
family that we thought might be gone who
in fact has returned as we saw in the
final moments of season 1 return of
Esther and what that might mean and you
know in the room
Julie has talked a lot about wanting to
incorporate a kind of dark warped fairy
tale component to this season and if the
first season was all about this harsh
gangster like take down of the vampire
factions in New Orleans this is the
season where our heroes are dealing with
the return their monstrous parents and
what that means to them I mean people
who watch The Vampire Diaries know
that's a bit of an understatement
calling us
like monsters pretty much the worst
Julie the season prepares title rebirth
can you talk about that sort of in
context of what we're gonna see
obviously refers to hope and sort of
where we left the end of last year yeah
well one of the things we like to do
with our titles is we like to name each
episode either a song lyric a song title
a book title or some kind of artist from
them actually the city of New Orleans
and so everything has anyone in this
context and rebirth of course is one of
the most famous brass bands in New
Orleans and they were in our pilot they
did the second line parade so it has
double meaning it's wanting to honor
that and then also just as you said
really just kind of conforming thank you
the idea of people starting over after
this grief that they all experienced or
at least have to both experience for
real and then fake experience for the
outside community and it's you know
what's everybody doing and how will they
begin again absolutely Joseph when we
return in season two where do we find
Klaus where's his head I mean he made a
lot of big choices at the end of seas
what excites you about what you've done
to do so far with season two there's a
lot of when we find him he's locked
himself away in the compound he's like a
caged animal waiting to make this move
you know to seek revenge on those who
contributed to the sending away of his
daughter he's been doing a lot of
painting you know which as we love the
metaphor is a metaphor for control so
he's trying to sort of control his
situation and control his emotions and
he's failing failing to control his
emotions and so we're going to see quite
quickly into season two
how Klaus seeks violent bloody merciless
revenge
[Music]
yeah and that in fact is what has
excited me most violent
trust where does Marcel fall in the fall
of that you know we saw him sort of
kissed the ring at the end of last
season seems to be back on team Klaus is
that sort of I want to go that easy
Alliance in the history of television
the least easy I think so no I mean I
like working with this guy so I hoping
good I hope the characters can get back
to a point where they're working
together as a team but yeah it was a
humbling experience
where's Marcel's head that does he feel
like he's gonna use Klaus until he no
longer needs Klaus and then he's maybe
gonna take this quarterback yeah he's a
vampire so he's got all eternity
I think he's gonna use this time to work
on expectations and things that Marcel
really wants to get into and now he
finally has the free time so in a way I
guess it's a blessing did you a favor to
see ya he's always looking out for me
sorry I love that no Phoebe obviously
one of the big changes to last season in
this season did you have
the prosthetic tummy a little bit I was
gonna be wanting to burn that baby bump
buddy and it got very good very
uncomfortable I think I had that bump on
for that a cool term I could have
actually been pregnant if it was on for
nine months that baby mom but you know
it was kind of sad now I kind of became
like part of the way that I walked and
how I could have acted and you know it
was kind of sad now that I've got
nowhere to hide my phone or my glasses
how many things could you stood in the
bump at a given time but my glasses my
phone and sometimes like a hot water
bottle I mean obviously that's not the
only difference she's now a hybrid which
is crazy and exciting what are you
stoked for the fans to see with this
sort of newer
more vicious Haley I mean I think what's
really cool is that
I mean it's real know it's been a
handbook but you know vampire werewolves
and especially for hybrids and Haley
really looks to Klaus for guidance you
know and that's what we've gotta find in
the second season that relationship and
that dynamic between the two of them
it's not really romantic she kind of
looks at classes a bit of a mentor and
there's some really lovely scenes where
class is literally like dying
step-by-step with like vamp hearing and
bad smell and things that Haley just
didn't know anything about and it's kind
of fun to kind of look at it like that
that you know you kinda have to stop I'm
like you know speak English
the beginning what not working a lot and
they're kind of working it out together
a little bit it's nice I was going to
say julienne of you I feel like from the
moment we you introduced from Vampire
Diaries I feel like Halley's gone on the
biggest journey maybe at this point
what are you sort of excited to be able
to write for that character now that
maybe you couldn't put forward you know
one of the best things about Hayley and
it sort of curses or the most is that we
met her at the Vampire Diaries
in spite of all the imaginations in what
she was doing and you know her deeper
did agenda was she just wanted answers
about her family and where she came from
and she got those answers and brought
her to New Orleans it got her into this
little mess with Klaus that that turned
into kind of a beautiful blessing and at
the end of it all after rallying the
werewolves around her drawing her family
together being part of this ascendant
Mikaelson family and giving birth to her
own child
she had to lose all of it yeah you know
so so what do you do you're her mother
without your child or you know you were
Mikaelson who can't really accept where
you fit in that family and you were a
prideful werewolf who now it is you know
hybrid which is the one thing that they
probably despise more than vampires so
she doesn't have a place and and
watching her try to find her own sense
of strength and her
place in this universe it's gonna be a
beautiful powerful journey one of the
most amazing things to sort of come out
of Elijah's role on the show was the
very nurturing relationship of heylia
that i think a lot of people you know
there's always a lot of conversations
about oh is this love triangle is this
an emotional bond I mean I feel like do
you just want to sort of put the story -
Reza's this sort of now that they have
this shared connection is it sort of
moved beyond the love triangle it's just
something more complicated I mean it's
exciting something still I mean
especially now that there's this sort of
necessary restrained like the you know
in fabricating this illusion of like
we've lost a child
they've been holed up in this in this
place for you know two to three months
and I think that there's goodness knows
what that had to have been like with the
malevolence of Klaus and kind of the
restraint of Elijah kind of wanting to
exact his revenge somewhere down the
road and Hayley somewhere in the middle
of that and also I think the lines you
would observe a degree of distance to
give
dignity you know I mean I love anything
parlor room gentleman like that I love I
mean I want to see them sort of continue
I want to see what you know what emerges
and blossoms from that you know I think
that there I mean first of all I just
love acting with her she's just amazing
and I don't want to see you know what
what becomes a bit I'm confused that
that I don't want that to be distorted
into I don't want anything to happen
conversations you know somebody
over the course of season one learned a
lot yeah and then was compelled to
forget a lot yeah oh yeah - Lauren
forgot some more I mean a lot of
learning in forgetting yeah learning and
forgetting for kami season one right but
now she knows she's on vervain she's got
her stuff together and she's like I'm
getting at here you guys are crazy
I'm gonna be a human and remove myself
from New Orleans but she's really
attracted to great bone structure
unfortunately I mean you know she
obviously has a lineage that would keep
her sort of in this power struggle given
the family so I mean what can you say
about how she fits into the fight for
the quarter this year um right now she's
trying to figure that out I I really
want to see her be the person she always
has been you season one was a lot of her
discovering mind-blowing things and
having to deal with this new reality she
finds herself in and I'm season two I'm
excited to see her be more comfortable
in her environment or just aware of her
environment and so you see you know the
the person she was all along was really
strong and
really morally grounded and a good
person in all this learning and
forgetting has she at least remember to
stop having sex in front of enchanted
dreamcatchers the evolution last year
was that she started someone I think a
lot of people weren't sure what she
really wanted she was on this incredible
journey she died came back as good as
evil she then resurrected what is wrong
with you what excites you about this new
seemingly exponentially colorful version
of Davina I think what's really cool
she's a lot stronger now
you know she's grown up a lot in the
past few months and coming back into
season 2 she's really kind of playing by
the rules now she's not gonna toss
around anymore is she she's not really
taking it from everyone now but I mean
it's an interesting sort of conundrum
she finds herself in because if Klaus is
her ultimate sort of victims she has to
contend with the fact that if she kills
him she would kill her bestie and she
would kill Marcel I mean which is a
great move on Klaus part I feel no I
think
yeah I think the biggest part about is
that she she's lost way too many people
that she cares about and I think now the
biggest thing for her and her biggest
strength is the people that she cares
about and that she loves but at the same
time it's her biggest weakness
absolutely for the guys for I just
arrived because we all started this
morning doing an interview together and
nobody could like make a sentence a
single one of us can formulate a clear
thought for Joseph and Daniel you know
by having Davina raining back your
parents into this world it obviously
presents an interesting sort of twist in
their feelings of family you know for a
long time that's all Klaus wanted was
just to have a family and now that he's
maybe has too much family maybe he
doesn't want to have I think you know
certainly bringing back Michael it's
gonna force him to sort of face up to
his relationship with his father and
then obviously how that translates into
him becoming a father and Hamid how much
of the way he's dealt with becoming a
father is due to how his father treated
him and how much of it is just his own
fault you know but as an actor it's
exciting because I get to work with
some of the actors again and as a show
you know being a show this place for our
family and called the originals it's
exciting to have some originals yeah I
mean it's also not just like you know
the blind crusade for family it's more
articulate than that it's about the
definition of family right now
I think and what it means the class and
Elijah and once they define that don't
poke at the kingdom that Michael talk a
little bit about what it means to bring
Esther and Michael back to the show and
sort of what that sets in motion for
season two what kind of explodes season
two in all the best ways you know when
we decided to get rid of the other side
on the Vampire Diaries we knew that this
was our shot our only shot and and we
talked about it a lot last year sort of
saying is this a road that we are ready
to go down because this is the only
chance we're going to get to bring his
characters back and what was so fun
about it is that it then defined really
the course of the whole season
storytelling because you know when your
greatest enemy is are the people that
actually gave you life and everything
that you have to do to defeat them is to
dig deep within yourself and find the
power that they stole from you
throughout your childhood in whatever
form and that's you know that's a huge
conflict and it's kind of Awesome no I
think if you strip away everything the
problem with being a vampire is that
your immortality
and the fact that you think of people as
food strips you of your connection to
humanity and you start to go a little
bit and what is interesting about the
Mikaelson family is they have a built-in
connection to their humanity in their
connection to one another and that's why
they cling for better or worse to their
family and now the very thing that they
cling to a lot is connection to Klaus
Klaus is connection to allege that their
love for this child their love for
Rebekah their love for Haley is now
coming into jeopardy and the antagonist
is their mother it is the person that
you should feel the most love from and
this person is coming back to judge them
as abominations and saying that for a
thousand years
you have reaped and you have sown and
now I am going to take that away from
you I'm going to have this agenda which
we will unpack over the course of the
season and in addition to that Davina
who lost the love of her life because of
Klaus as machinations has brought back
Michael and now has him on a leash and
he has this desperate agenda to get even
with the bastard Faust so the people
that should love you the most your mom
and your dad want to destroy you so if
you're already mad and
crazy because of this horrible situation
of being a vampire and now you're
completely losing your humanity because
even the family that you have relied on
us starting to attack you things are
gonna start to implode and that's what
we're dealing with the originals I think
that's a yeah but you know what you
brought the r-word Rebecca I'm curious I
mean obviously we saw Claire in the
finale she's open to coming back and
would you have any plans to have her
back in season to start well I can't say
that the trailer you guys house actually
is footage from the first three episodes
and so there was her smiling little face
so you know we're gonna severely sports
[Applause]
bring her back
well the whole point is out of a Keith
you know the secret that hope is alive
out of New Orleans while still trying to
make New Orleans a home for hope which
is now starting to sound like a hallmark
commercial
we sit in the writers room when we think
like how could we get that moment that
we're all dying to see please we're
dying to save a dynasty of you know
where Haley and the clouds maybe get to
hold their child again and and not be
and not to be in the context where
they're stupid they're putting you know
her in jeopardy so I hope that we can
find that this year one of the other
faces we saw in the trailer I think was
Daniel Sharman he plays in this world in
which of these guys he ends up
interacting like I mean he's Caleb he's
naughty like naughty mysterious what
this guy want
[Music]
[Applause]
great actor
would you say he's kind of dream
if I were you I'd say Davina Davina
meets Caleb and bit smitten and but
she's also not really ready to trust
people right now either so he's it's
gonna have our time can understand why
she'll be a little interesting I've just
anyone
Charles what about Marcel I mean I feel
like he you know had like I said some
dreamcatcher lovin but beyond that is
there anything more
[Music]
I'm not trademarking anything I'm just
saying yeah that's how we watched it
what can you sort of say about what the
future holds for him whether it's with
kami or another one of his many suitors
there's definitely some romance I think
carried over from season one we'll get
to you in a minute look at that
chemistry look at the chemistry yeah so
there's still some of this there the
door is also open for any additional
shipping and romance but I think Marcel
has his hands full with trying to
rebuild his vampire community which has
been whittled down to him in charge once
you introduce this character you're like
we we love him and the audience seems to
be super into him - all right most of
the writers from our staff actually in
the audience and I will now say in front
of God and everybody
but about three episodes deep I was like
before have you seen any footage I said
okay good it's time to start planning
now how we're gonna kill Josh you know
like supporting character
kill Josh it'd be great death and all
the writers in a room like if you kill
Josh you were the enemy of all things
good thing but that's the point like
ever and back from Kevin in the master
really understand himself is like you'd
kill the characters you might that's
what takes people by surprise so I'm
gonna do that okay so in this episode so
they say oh we're in this battle and I
say and then Josh dies and they would
all go no to anyway and then I started
watching Josh so like oh I really like
him he's good and I should kill him cuz
I like him so much but that's a great
guy but he's you know he's he's Josh she
can't we're talking about love is there
any chance of love for Josh this season
itself yeah absolutely a hundred percent
there's chance for love for anybody but
there's definitely a chance roll up for
Josh I mean if we're gonna keep him
around
he is one of them ourselves guys one of
Marcel's the last guys what is it like
to be a vampire werewolf occupy New
Orleans he's gonna be fighting for his
life and trying to survive and in that
circumstance that's the last thing
you're looking for and the first thing
you wind up finding which is you know of
romantic interest so that's definitely
something we want to do so if single
people want to find love
okay well you know one of the other
things I'm curious about that you guys
did really amazing last year with Tyler
was the Vampire Diaries are rich in
those crossover it's appropriate we'll
do that for you guys how do you define
when it's appropriate to have something
like that happen it's two very different
sets of rules the first is creative in a
second is logistics creatively it's just
gotta feel like it exists only and
solely in the universe of the originals
like it fits like a glove so perfectly
that this story could not be told
without that elements and we have you
know a great picture on the table right
now that if we you know if we're
successful in playing the b-side of it
together which is logistics you know
maybe we will have some kind of
crossover opportunity this season the
logistical side of it of course is a
freaking McMahon because you're you know
you're talking about somebody who's on
another show trying to get their
schedules to coordinate with your
schedule in a city where it rains you
know and you're moving from set to set
and then you know they're things happen
and you burn sets down and then you have
to you know shift your schedule and
stuff like that and so anything can mess
up the perfect crossover opportunity so
we just kind of keep our fingers crossed
see I mean with you guys working such
long hours on such dramatic material
what is sort of the key to keeping it
light on set I'm you know all right are
there prank people do you just all sort
of everybody just left
I think this is an appropriate time to
share with you how Daniel Gillies dented
my car each other just just little
things like you put a traffic cone in my
parking spot I cross my parking spot so
while he was getting in the makeup
trailer I took his keys and drove his
car around the back of the studio and
little things like that I made a little
bigger of my sound holding a sign saying
a cat holding a sign with his face when
they say carrying that he'll give you
since 2011 he decided one day to like it
would be really funny to pop really
close to my truck so I couldn't move and
then obviously cuz Circle is in fact
Edison signed it and had to come in and
all sort of shameful in
$600.00 place so you so we're not
talking like saran wrap on the toilet
it's just like vehicular damage and just
like serious money extremely open this
up to fan questions now so you guys can
chat with the cast I believe there's
just a mic there let's line up in an
orderly fashion and everything would be
incredible hey guys just quickly before
we do the end wouldn't mind could you
join with me in a chorus of happy
birthday for Paul Wesley
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Daniel Gillies I love you
[Applause]
so my questions for Michael and Julie I
really love the music that's included
with all the episodes every week and I
was wondering how you go through the
process of choosing the music and do you
like approve it personally or do you
have a team that does it I personally
play yeah and this is true in the
Vampire Diaries as well those team of
editors that are so extraordinary dialed
into their musical voice I'm the musical
voice of the show in a way they created
that voice for us and and we just got to
say Oh God for you guys it's a team our
co-executive producer Lance Anderson who
was been with the vampire essence
episode two has like he's he's the guy
that puts in the bottom there and you
know and the great tracks and the finds
the great music and then you add to that
New Orleans jazz and though in the
footprint of the musical signature of
the city it's just this this like
[Music]
[Laughter]
some whatever and then I've worked my CV
the composer is so dialed into the
universe as well to see to the Vampire
Diaries so music beautifully is the
least difficult part of mics and my job
because the people who handle it a lot
with music supervisor Chris molera are
so so so good at it yeah Chris malaria
deserves a huge shot for finding all
this stuff and you could follow on
Twitter because he posts every song in
every episode on Vampire Diaries and the
original so you can go download it and
there's such great songs I don't know if
I'm allowed to do this but I wanted to
say this in episode 21 stop the Battle
of New Orleans when Elijah walks out
into the middle of the compound
surrounded by an army of vampires and he
meets his brother and then class goes
off to fight Marcel and daniel has this
beautiful moment racist gentleman
showering you know he's so great that
wasn't originally set to a song that we
didn't get the rights to No yeah
Thanksgiving that and I say what that
song works cuz it's so awesome you can
they give us the right but it was a
blunderbuss by Jack White it's so good
and we should listen to that song again
and again but that's it it just became
my worse so
I mean in this discussion of your
incredible behind-the-scenes team it
should also be noted that you guys got
an Emmy nomination this year that
episode that that Colleen submitted for
the team was it's very subtle but in the
very first two minutes of the episode
they were gonna flash to like all the
rules Celeste has played over the
decades and so in one little tense at
the moment she had to do like seven
errors and hairstylists not to mention
that it was a flashback episode as well
as well so I think well deserved her
super
hi this message is for Joseph and Daniel
since Klaus is always the evil evil evil
person do you think that after season 2
will anybody home Klaus be able to be
redeemed because everybody says Klaus is
so evil he can't be redeemed but we hope
there's a chance for redemption you know
of redemption for him I like the idea
that the series ultimately could be that
journey for him to redemption I think if
there's any hope of getting there he's
gonna need the help of his family and
this is adoptive family as well so yeah
I don't know this interesting question I
mean they question of redemption because
I like what Michael said earlier before
about you know human beings being a
source of food so us being the viewers
know we're like did this standards of
morality are far different you know my
friend of mine who is a big fan of the
show once articulated is like a group of
humans who have basically been marooned
on an island of really intelligent
monkeys there's a sort of the equivalent
of the of the originals on earth you
know and it must it must be incredibly
long as sort of for them and and I don't
really think of these guys in terms of
sort of good and evil but they I do
think they admire humanity
you know I think they had my asset of
aspects of humanity and sort of yearned
for them and some of them pursue that
goodness as we simply sieve it more
vigorously than others but I think
they're just so tortured by this kind of
alienation release my people I work with
it's awesome my favorite show on TV
right now my question is for the whole
panel I wanted to know what was your
favorite moment from season one I was
saying goodbye to my uncle for the last
time and the end
[Applause]
bombarded with memories now I like
watching a classic farewell to his child
anon in three waves of onion strange
about it no I love that I even loved
with enough one that's the sound summer
self-aggrandizing but I couldn't even
love just seems with camera the light
during camp being sort of walking in
into the universe it was I remember just
being thrilled at seeing that the family
had just come to town I'm not part of
any of it and that's why I love it so
much but all the flashbacks I'm so
jealous when you guys get to kind of
walk out of the makeup and hair trailers
and stuff with weeds and kind of this
amazing these amazing costumes I mean
the production value on our show and who
would that work you know costume
department our hair department obviously
she's gotten her name for an Emmy but
I'm beso talented and they're really
shows in those scenes and they're so
beautiful to watch and even just when
you see them being shot when the stages
they really beautiful so
[Music]
that's my favorite I mean I think you
know the one time saying goodbye to my
baby was something that I feel like we
aren't through the whole season and it
was a real gift to have a scene like
that that was really really great and
then fight in Episode they doing that
fight which was a huge piece of
choreography and taking a day and a half
to film it in the compound wrap you know
which ends with myself picking up the
coin that was one of my favorite things
as well I like the sort of stunt
elements of it
the reaction that we brought to the
Charlotte of us that was exciting to me
my favorite personal moment was episode
11 after the Vina dives and then I rush
back slit throat you just when Marcel
rushes back to the to the compound and
then class is there and yeah I watched
it on YouTube
I loved that cliff and I loved seeing
all the little comments so like I cried
my eyes out because in like that was in
it it made me cry but also seen that you
did in the very beginning I think it was
like episode 2 or 3 and you're having a
conversation with your brother and
sister and you're talking finally
speaking your point and just have one
single tear and I was like Denzel
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
my favorite to film was the scene right
before I died so I don't know I know
that dude choked you luck but beautiful
moment between Marcel and Davina and
he's been like the only family that
she's had and her finally getting to say
goodbye and being strong enough to do so
I thought that was a really there's a
fun scene to film I mean walking up with
the fire and rain it was really fun to
film and you make a decision to just
don't yeah it looked really cool to
family I love that part and then also my
favorite to watch really I loved
watching Hayley hold her baby for the
first time
I mean Julia Michael put the question to
you as well but if that like the
ultimate Sophie's Choice to pick a scene
from the show rate in 22 episodes
yeah yeah but if I can show something
that never did she wrote he's you know
professor Medici it's so brilliant his
voice is so poetic and and he wrote the
line and Benedict what's right about the
Rebecca says it to class when they're
finally had it out right before she
leaves and she says we are the
definition of curse and in our day she
can help remind me what the the pray
that did that was but it's like we're
stuck with each other always in forever
we can never die we can never split that
is true the definition of curse I just
thought that was so sad and I was like
would you like that what you need to
pick something Julie yeah the beautiful
moment when Rebecca is confessing to
father Kieran that she is going to she
has betrayed you know her her family by
betraying claps at the top of episode of
AIDS that was a script
Julie and Declan wrote which I just am
so envious of I want to cry
great stuff and yeah I think their
journey that Rebecca went on and the
season from deciding to betray her
brother you know looking at Klaus of the
eye and choosing to lie and say I don't
know what myself is planning against you
and then turning on her own brother and
leading this revolt against Klaus and
then trying to get Davina to join
against Klaus and ultimately the
revelation of what her past sins were by
working with Mark my Marcel to bring in
Michael and then you know finally having
her confrontation with Klaus and then
deciding to leave and being they did
yeah
[Applause]
thank you very much for your question
next yeah that's a good question
I'm TJ I'm from Texas and this is my
first time asking a question at the
community panel first off I just want to
say all you guys are awesome
and then I'm grieving for Hailey and
Elijah my questions for Julie Plec how
since hopes I guess you call her a
tribrid how she effect the supernatural
world and the Vampire Diaries and Mystic
Falls well that's a really good question
um you know right now she's just a baby
and and if Rebecca does her job right
she's maybe that's gonna be born and I'm
sorry and live a perfectly human
existence where her vampire side or her
a werewolf gene will never be triggered
or her she'll never know to practice
witchcraft but you know people in those
situations tend to not do their jobs
very well and so you know the theme of
the season this you know childbearing is
complicated so I think exploring what
hope means to the whole supernatural
universe and and what person sort of put
upon her as a result of what she is it's
actually gonna be part of this season
and
and tie into a lot of the agendas of our
villains and so as for what it does to
mr. Cobbs I yeah about that one
hopefully nothing that you haven't
thought about it if you guys can make
baby he'll kill someone and then trigger
the werewolf curse that will be the
coolest thing that trips over her and
falls down
thank you next question hi this is for
Phoebe hi what inspiration did you draw
on for this season and becoming a hybrid
I guess you know what we find Haley it's
three months after the finale and we
we've kind of find Haley and she's just
kind of a mess right now she's very lost
and she doesn't really know what her
intention is right now she doesn't
really know what she's fighting for but
anything's worth fighting for
at all and she's kind of a bit of like
on a chemical mission she's really got
nothing to lose but I mean I mean ever
nothing is answering your question or
not but you know I guess it's been kind
of fun to kind of work with these guys
even just as an actress because you know
I came on the show as a werewolf and I
never got to do any of the kind of bad
hybrid stuff so just like learning the
technical part of it like Daniel and I
did the same right they actually got cut
from the finale and I had to UM it was
bad I took by his name and I didn't know
how to do it I kind of didn't I just you
know I know I didn't ask anyone I just
know how to do it i watch they shoot for
a while
what to do it and I made sound fish and
interesting enough it was an ice cream
eat it she's that kind of that the
technical side of life learning how to
actually act like you know I know so
mining from like what they've done the
Vampire Diaries and it's um you know
just learning that kind of stuffs been
fun but I'm excited to be a hybrid now
it's gonna be good
thank you for your question thank you
hi my name is the CC Anna this is for
the past members that have been on the
Vampire Diaries set what do you like
more about being on the originals
we have more selection of entrees
I've been a huge plus for me and less
amount of shirtless scenes on our show
huge food I don't really know who to ask
this question to you I just I mean it's
dark clouds and Caroline I just put it
up and like you were talking about
hostel server crossovers earlier so I
was curious if there is gonna be any
more Caroline in class sweetheart you'll
guess is as good as mine
you know the web is actually answering
this question earlier and and I got a
lot of nods people like oh when you
agree with you and secretly they
probably like screw you you're horrible
but you know what I was saying is in
order for Caroline to enter the New
Orleans universe and engage with Klaus
on any level there's got to be a fit an
organic fit and and that can take some
time before the world of the originals
will will accept that you know make that
fit and so it could be it could be it
could not be it could be later you know
it's like we we have to wait for an
organic opportunity to bring these two
together we do because you know they do
have unfinished business
there there is no place for Caroline and
classes community at the moment because
of what is
[Music]
thank you for your question next spring
hi my name's Julian my questions for
Phoebe I just wanted to know after doing
the h2o what drew you to play Haley what
Julie to play Haley I mean I was very
lucky that I was kind of introduced to
this world 5 Kevin Williamson on The
Secret Circle and king of Queen of Comic
Con in Julie and Kevin he's very lucky
I've been on kind of two shows but you
know I was kind of introduced to the
world by Kevin and then you know the
opportunity to be a part of vampire
always came up kind of straightaway and
I I really just wanted to be part of the
world
I kind of was kind of happy to really
play any character and you know I was so
fortunate that the character that I got
to play was such a interesting and
complicated and dynamic and a character
and a character that's kind of evolved
over vampire eyes over the first season
and then especially when we find Haley
at the beginning of the second season
but thank you for watching h2o it's it's
fun to play it like a non naive little
16 year old girl and no one believes
that I played like a very innocent that
old
nine years ago but you know it's fun I
feel like I'm like drawn to these
supernatural characters and they're a
lot more fun to play I think than that
boring old humans sorry Leah this is for
Jesse
I was wondering how does class change
after me after his baby's taken away I
know it's hard for Klaus well thank you
for the study you know I believe that
hope was his home she was she was hoped
for him for to be a better man hybrid
and creature you know she was his hope
for him for redemption and her being
taken away takes into a very very dark
place and surprisingly he he's as we
mentioned he's locked himself away and
spent a lot of time planning the brutal
bloody murders of anyone who was
involved in separating him from
daughter so I think I think we can
safely say he's in a worse place than he
was when when she was around my question
is the class character in the books the
vampire diaries' is greatly different
than what is in the show how do you feel
about playing the characters so
differently than was in the book well in
the book he's a new book and he's in it
for a sort of limited time but he's
built up to be this you know this
fearsome force which is what it was
initially when he came to vampire
diaries the show I mean we had to kind
of develop him further because there
just wasn't in as much source material
than in the book one of the things that
I was excited about was the fact that
he's a hybrid and then the whole thing
about the original family came out which
was extremely exciting exciting for me
but one of the things I really wanted to
take from the resulting he killed Vicky
in the book and he I think he left her
dead on the bed and he wrote goodnight
sweetheart on the mirror and blood and
he left the record playing that's where
I got the idea that's where the
sweetheart came from you know calling
woman sweetheart and using a term of
affection
very creepy way so I sort of that was a
lot to the fans of the book I think but
for me it's been exciting to develop it
further and hopefully kind of still stay
faithful to the source material
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you